on a tous besoin de relâcher clairement
mais maintenant oui ça me choque la
différence de traitement c'est toujours
choquant la plupart des français font
hyper attention on nous demande d'être
mobilisés et du coup c'est évidemment
choquant que le traitement soit pas le
même pour tout le monde c'est toujours
les mêmes en fait qui qui ont enfin tout
cas où on a vraiment l'impression qu'ils
que tout leur est permis en fait et ils
ont droit à des choses auxquelles les
gens n'ont pas droit non ça ne choque
pas parce que au jour d'aujourd'hui
les gens ça fait un moment qu'ils ont
pas mis les pieds dans un resto
les restaurateurs eux aussi ils payent
des loyers ils ont besoin d'ouvrir son
besoin de faire un chiffre d'affaires en
fait au mois mais ce qui est impossible
avec le co vide et c'est donc bon qu'ils
ouvrent clandestinement
c'est un fait c'est illégal mais on peut
le comprendre au scénar notre côté donc
ça me choque pas tant que ça alors c'est
les gens du cou qui nous gouvernent qui
pratiquent ce genre de faits
dans ce cas là c'est pas que ça me
choque mais c'est que je trouve ça un
peu un peu un peu excusez moi du terme
un peu bête parce que d'un côté vous
nous dites voilà restez chez vous
n'allez pas au resto vous fermez les
restos etc
c'est pour y aller dépenser des sommes
et en plus tu vas manger et sans se
soucier du coc vide et que nous en
partie le peuple voilà on n'a pas droit
d'y aller c'est une injustice c'est
l'injustice et bien sûr que ces hommes
là quand ils vont ces hommes et ces
femmes quand ils vont au restaurant ils
vont pas subir les mêmes conséquences
que nous on pourrait subir en tout cas
si nous on se fait attraper sur ces
faits là bas j'ai pas cette information
là dans l'hypothèse que c'est vrai moi
je pense que il a il incarne l'état il
incarne les décisions de cet état là
donc ils doivent eux être le symbole où
l'idéal à suivre et si s'ils répondent
pas s'il n'applique pas ce qu'ils
demandent aux citoyens ils font perdre
la crédibilité à au pouvoir qu'ils ont
et du coup je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise chose si ça s'avère que c'est
vrai donc je pense qu'il va falloir
faire attention à son comportement si on
est ministre
je sais très bien que c'est pas légal
mais je les comprends parce qu'ils sont
en faillite et peut-être qu'ils essayent
de sauver leur compte en banque
non non je dois je comprendre je vois
pas pourquoi il irait faire ça ça serait
pas très intelligent
moi je comprends que la pression elle
est assez importante sur les
restaurateurs et que 20 pour pour la
plupart ils voient la fin de leur
business
du coup c'est sûr que c'est mal au
niveau de la loi mais je les comprends
qu'il veuille garder leur business je
pense qu'ils ont un attachement et qu'il
voulait bien le faire le faire grandir
ou que le juste le garder donc c'est
compréhensible moi je pense que ces
ministres devaient tous nous inviter
comme ça parce que ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas eu ce genre n'a pas été
dans un resto et du coup si l'invité
tout le monde ça serait beaucoup plus
sympa quoi est ce que je comprends non
je pense qu'ils doivent ils doivent
incarner ce qu'ils disent donc c'est un
peu dommage
donc s'il ya une crise de la confiance
là on est en train de l'alimenter donc
vaut mieux éviter des comportements
comme ça